ومن المؤكد أن هناك شيئًا ما
يلسع الحقائب على الظهر هذه يخص
الملايو وتوأم ميزا البالغان من العمر سبع سنوات من جوبا
ذرة روث.
وقع هجوم بالأسلحة الكيماوية المزعومة ودولي
كانوا يتنفسون بصعوبة شعرت أن جسدها
يتعرج ، وشقت طريقها إلى أعلى وهي تسحب جثة
ابنتها ولكن بعد ذلك بدأت الضربات الأخرى
كنا بين حالتي وفاة
تتذكرها إما من
الضربات الكيماوية أو الآخرين على السطح
لا تزال الرائحة قوية جدًا بالنسبة لي ، هذه
هي الأشياء التي لم يتمكنوا من
مشاهدتها ، نعم ، هذه هي اللعبة التي
أخفتها ابنتها في محاولة للحفاظ على
سلامتها وستخبر اللعبة التي تعلم
أنك قد تختنق بها ولكن في
على الأقل ستكون في مأمن من القصف
وهذه هي الطريقة التي تعمل بها عقول الأطفال
بالأمس كانوا يحفرون
نفقًا للنمل
حتى لا يختنق النمل في حالة
حدوث شيء ما.
في خيمة أخرى ، التقينا بصبي
ندبة خشنة تمر عبر بطنه ،
كان عمه الذي لا يريد الكشف عن
هويته من بين أسوأ العوامل التي أثرت
على الأسرة في الضربة الكيماوية التي
قال إنها أخذت عينة دمه في اليوم
السابق لهذا المخيم الجديد  يسكنها
أولئك الذين نجوا من حصار الهلاك
، وهو قصف لا هوادة فيه استمر لمدة شهر
دفع العائلات إلى العمل تحت الأرض بحيث كان
شيء بسيط مثل
الشعور بجلدهم هو رفاهية ريم ،
واعتقدت عائلتها أن القصف كان هدوءًا
وخرجت  عندما قالت إن
ثلاث غارات جوية ضربت بجوارها مباشرة ،
فإن الشيء التالي الذي تتذكره هو أنها كانت
في المستشفى كانت قد
خرجت للتو من الجراحة في المستشفى
عندما كان الجرحى من الضربة الكيماوية ،
كما تقول ، قد بدأوا في القدوم إلى
مكان الحادث كان مروعاً للغاية.
نسيت آلامها ، ما لا
تعرف ما لا يملكه أحد ليقول
لها هو أن زوجها قد مات ، ابنها
البالغ من العمر عامين فقط هو أصغر من أن
يتذكر والده الحد الأقصى  د ش
ربما تكون الضربات الفرنسية البريطانية قد أرسلت
رسالة إلى النظام السوري بشأن
الأسلحة الكيماوية ولكن ليس عن
بقية ترسانتها لأولئك الذين
تحملوا ما لا يمكن تصوره ، إنها ليست
أكثر من مجرد تحرك على
رقعة شطرنج مروعة وصل فيفزي البالغ من العمر 68 عامًا إلى
هنا قبل أربعة أيام.  من دوما
دفنت الكثير من الأقارب إلى المقاطعة
بما في ذلك ابنها واثنين من أحفادها
، لم يتبق لهم شيء ، أعني
أنه حتى لو تمكنوا من العودة إلى المنزل ،
لم يتبق شيء يفعله
، تقول إن بلدها تسبب لها في
الكثير من الألم وتتذكر الضياع منذ فترة طويلة
الأيام التي كانت فيها عائلتها حولها عندما
كانوا على قيد الحياة عندما
لم يكن الشعور بالأمان من الرفاهية ، كل هذا فقط كانت
أروى ديمون ترى آنا وأحضرت مخيم اللاجئين في
سوريا